[Música]
que lleve el momento de repasar los
titulares de la prensa internacional con
Rosa Pérez más de rosa bienvenida a buen
día feliz martes para ti comenzamos en
Ecuador el Estado decepción en ese país
con el universo el diario de Ecuador y
también el mercurio Rosa buenos días
exacto Raúl nos hemos querido fijar en
distintas problemáticas ahora mismo a
las que hacer frente no pues este país
vecino
el comercio con drogas tiene mucho que
ver también con la desigualdad social y
por otro lado también esto la ley de 20
y me dará el delincuente no al policía
en relación a esta unidad es defensa
legal de la fuerza pública con la que el
presidente ecuatoriano blinda las
actuaciones no pues a los agentes de la
fuerza pública y como dijo indultar a
cualquier agente que haya sido condenado
por cumplir con su labor Rosa vamos
ahora con el diario de Ecuador esta es
la editorial de este diario el gobierno
debe respetar los ofrecimientos a Manabí
medio El Diario de Ecuador pues se fija
en las regiones en las provincias de
Manabí y Esmeraldas porque son las
Fuerzas Armadas y precisamente el que
estás fueron las
que más de 70
las regiones están todavía por
reconstruir que esta es una deuda que
tengo que tiene el Estado gobierne quién
gobierne pero que además las o prometió
estar reconstrucción y durante su
campaña electoral vamos ahora al
mercurio indígenas llegan a la Corte
Constitucional por la Corte
Constitucional por planes estrictas
planes estrictos en Amazonia
llama R derecho internacional derecho de
los pueblos indígenas a la consulta
previa pero que por otro lado estos
proyectos dañan no solamente sus
territorios sino la salud de todo el
planeta y pues de toda la humanidad
ahora vamos con un tema de importancia
que ocurrió ayer la muerte
y precisamente no es este discurso que
dio ante las Naciones Unidas lo que
señalan también los otros medios que
ahora vamos a comentar pero el York
Times también pues remarca que a Colin
Powell a pesar de haber trabajado sobre
todo para administraciones en
republicanas Boisaca vio acabó apoyando
a Obama y más tarde a Hillary Clinton
como candidatos presidenciales en
Francia con liberación dice muere el
arquitecto de la guerra estadounidense
de Irak rosa
y
yo
formará parte de mi historial vamos a
Reino Unido de cardigan Rosa el discurso
de Colin Powell Naciones Unidas un
momento decisivo en el socavamiento en
la credibilidad de Estados Unidos
hubiera invadido igual y por otro lado
no convenció al Consejo de Seguridad de
Naciones Unidas
acabó la credibilidad de Estados Unidos
porque el insistía en que estás pruebas
de armas de destrucción masiva estaban
basadas en pruebas de inteligencia super
firmes y eso pues no fácil pero son
muchísimas gracias entonces es por todo
esto sus titulares de la prensa nosotros
ahora vamos con nuestro primer invitado
al día gracias Rosa